the official line in turkey remains that
the killing of Armenian Christians a
hundred years ago was not a genocide
rule and Bill mez is one of the few
historians in Turkey who has openly
disagreed with the government he's
convinced that most Turkish people
aren't in the dark either despite the
official denials this crime isn't just
about those who were killed that
property was confiscated to their
churches were destroyed everyone saw it
and the government knows it too they're
using this defensive strategy to try to
just get through the anniversary while
opinions vary most Turkish people don't
dispute the fact that Armenians were
killed but say they weren't the only
victims of the first world war it was
wartime this shouldn't have happened but
unfortunately both the Armenians and the
Turks suffered losses these people have
brought published their evidence of a
genocide if they have any
we should recognize the genocide and
apologize to the Armenian people not a
widely held opinion in Turkey but a very
important one for the country's small
Armenian minority journalists at this
Istanbul Armenian newspaper want to hear
it from the lips of the country's
leaders the government would have given
more than its condolences we would have
liked to see them taking steps to make
it easier for society to come to terms
with the truth the schumak do more
nations are beginning to refer to the
killings of Armenians as genocide
increasing the pressure on Turkey to
come to grips with its past